just a few weeks ago Sonic the Hedgehog
started a shitstorm wave in the trailer
because of his human appearance the
outrage was so great that they decided
to change the appearance of the
protagonist Sonic now paramount
announced how long the release date will
be delayed namely by three months the
reason is obvious the CGI and 3d artists
need a lot more time in post-production
to completely rework the main character
director Jeff Fowler wrote on Twitter we
are taking the time to make the sonic
movie right the story revolves around
the alien peeing sonic known to many
from comics and video games of the same
name who is on the route from dr. Eggman
played by Jim Carrey Sonic's new release
date is now February 14th 2020 a few
days ago the shooting of Black Widow
started in Norway but now the first news
from the set has been leaked questioning
the assumption that Black Widow will be
set as a prequel some fans even think
that the Black Widow solar movie could
play during Avengers and came the reason
for this are shots from the set in a
small village in Norway where Scarlett
Johansson ruts the same hairstyle as in
Avengers endgame long red hair with plum
tips in addition the location Norway
also speaks for the fact that a solo
film plays parallel to M game sure these
could be clues however they are not
really valid nevertheless you can assume
that in the future Marvel movies you'll
get to know the skip gears an endgame
even better we are rather of the opinion
that Black Widow will play during an
game at times but that the focus will be
on the background story of Natasha
Romanov as a SHIELD agent Black Widow
will probably be shown in cinemas in the
middle of next year it recently became
known that cult director Steven
Spielberg is currently planning another
film adventure for the Indiana Jones
series so far so good
however Spielberg doesn't want Harrison
Ford as the main character anymore but a
new face this doesn't seem to have twist
for it so much as shortly afterwards he
said in an interview with the u.s.
channel NBC nobody will be Indiana Jones
don't you understand
I am Indiana Jones when I'm not around
anymore he's gone it's that simple
his possible successors as a
web-swinging archaeologist are crisp
or Chris Pratt will lucasfilm and Steven
Spielberg listen to Harrison Ford
that's quite questionable since both
have great interest in continuing the
cult series probably even without a 78
year old fort but to be sure we have to
be patient for a while because neither
Spielberg nor Lucas art said anything
about fort statements yet this summer
the production of Martin Scorsese's and
Leonardo DiCaprio's movie killers of the
flower moon which have been planned for
a long time was supposed to start but
that won't happen for now the reason for
this is the post production of
Scorsese's mega project the irishman
which will be released on Netflix at the
end of the year the Mafia thriller with
Robert DeNiro Al Pacino and Joe Pesci
shows several time levels in which the
actors are digitally made younger with a
very elaborate method this is so
time-consuming that Scorsese has no time
this summer to produce killers of the
flower moon which is supposed to be
about the beginning time of the FBI and
contains DiCaprio as main actor in the
meantime other productions of the two
will be released
like Scorsese's Rolling Thunder revue a
Bob Dylan story on Netflix On June 12
DiCaprio will be featured in Quentin
Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood in the States on the 26th of
July Warner has been developing an and
keira film based on the anime model for
several years now the film Jayant has
already secured the rights in 2009 now
there are news regarding the release
date as well as the director the
directors position was filled with Taika
Waititi and that's not too much of a
surprise as he already outed himself in
an interview a year ago as a big fan of
the series and at the same time made
clear that he doesn't want to produce a
remake of the 80's anime pill instead he
wants to stick strictly to the manga
original and commit mainly Asian and not
so well-known actors for his cast in the
focus of the story is a young motorcycle
gang which is involved in all kinds of
conflicts alongside other groups they
are competing in a tough race for the
mysterious akira who lies in a
laboratory and whose awakening is
supposed to come through up the
apocalypse until this story is made into
a film watch it he has other projects
especially his war satire of Georgia
rabbit which will be shown in cinemas in
autumn after
that the production will be started
quickly after all akira will be released
in the cinemas in may 2021 the tenth
season of The Walking Dead is currently
being filmed however without the former
lead actor Andrew Lincoln that he hasn't
completely disappeared from the Walking
Dead universe was somehow clear but we
didn't know when and how on Twitter
there was a promising answer from
Skybound namely that an update will be
released earlier than expected so the
three announced recraft spin-offs
weren't forgotten and you probably get
new updates soon
[Music]